[Music]
I just seem to be in a constant state of
distractability and frustration and
avoidance my friends and husband have
all gone on to become respectable adults
who earn money who keep on studying and
learning Emma you grew three human
beings and you kept them
[Music]
alive hey what's up this this is John
with the Dr John deloney
show some say the greatest mental health
in marriage and relationships dating
parenting whatever you got going on your
life YouTube Show podcast so glad that
you've joined us um we're here in
Nashville Tennessee and if you want to
come visit us we've got free coffee and
cookies and the studio out here you can
come watch the show hang out afterwards
and if you want to be on the show and
this show is about real people going
through real challenges in their life if
you want to be on on this show and give
me a buzz and we'll sit down and figure
out what's the next right step give me a
call at
33291 it's 1844 693 3291 or go to John
dooney.com askk what what I no you did
everything fine I forgot I realized
yesterday because we were running a
little late um as we are today that I
did not
say Do you happen to know who the NFC
East Champion was do you do you know who
oh the Cowboys yeah I just want to make
sure that everybody was clear on that
now Realize by the time this airs it
could all have gone fantastically wrong
hey but all we care about or we could be
getting ready for the Super Bowl all we
care about is that the Eagles have found
their way down the toilet D fire correct
and to my friend Jaylen yes I'm talking
to you Jaylen you've been texting me and
blowing me up asking me what size Eagles
jersey Kelly and I would want to
wear say a chance in hell I may have I
may have bet that you and I would do
that I had faith which clearly you don't
we play them we're not right now and
we're not slated to play them next week
either no we're not going to play them
because they're not going even make it
they're going to be out next week and
and chances are even if they won this
weekend we're still not going to play
them chances are yeah right chances are
I was about to say but look at the world
around us so chances are lot things you
know Any Given Sunday blah blah blah
exactly so I just wanted to make sure we
were all clear on who the NFC East
Champion was we're we're all clear go
Astros all right so if you want to be on
this show if you want to be on the show
1844 693 3291 leave a message it can be
long it can be detailed sometimes people
write out what their question is and
they just read that question over um the
voicemail or go to john.com askk and you
can write it in a Word document cut and
paste it drop it in there and we'll get
you on the show let's go out to
Minneapolis Minnesota oh by the way
before we go to Minneapolis please take
a second and like or subscribe to show
it makes such a difference if you're on
the tubes um we've got some pretty
audacious subscription goals this year I
want to blow the roof off and we did it
with social media this year we did it
with the size of the show we want to do
it with our uh subscriptions to YouTube
so go to YouTube hit subscribe and let's
knock the top off this thing all right
now let's go out to Minneapolis and talk
to TJ what's up
TJ hi Dr John thanks for taking my call
of course man how are
you uh doing better than I deserve I
guess excellent excellent I like it so
what's up man
um just calling to see how I can change
my behavior longterm to help save my
marriage what's going
on um there's been some recent arguments
I've had with uh my wife and come to the
point where she's stated that she's
weighing the options of divorce and
um basically Pinnacle from I don't uh
respect her and I don't value her
decisions and her opinions and ideas and
criticize her too much is she
right
definitely
H I would say so so what's what's the I
guess the logical question is tell me
about your reasons for treating her that
way cuz based on what you just said if
she was my daughter she was my sister I
would say yeah dude I'll help you out
I'll call the lawyer for
you yeah hey just in the moments I guess
I
don't don't think about how she feels
about
stuff guess why do you wait till the
moment I don't know I I don't really
think about her opinion I guess I don't
know if it's a selfish thing or yeah
1,000% how long have you been
married it'll be 10 years on the 1 of
February okay so this been going on a
long time has it always been this way
and she just said I just can't do it
anymore um actually we talked about that
and she did say that when we first met
it wasn't like this at all we met in
high school we were a different point in
our life than we are now but then when
we first met I full Comm Collective
never got worked up about anything and
now he doesn't see that anymore
so what's happened in your life man that
you've become somebody you don't want to
be somebody that you didn't used to be
but now you
are I I don't really know I guess I've
had a lot of Life Changes since that
point in my life and well we all had
Life Changes man but we don't all treat
our
wife the way you treat yours as though
there's somebody not worthy of
us
I I
guess is she not doing something is she
not stepping up to the I here's the deal
I don't care about in the moment in the
moment is an
excuse like if I surround if I go to the
grocery store and I buy tons of junk
food and I fill my house up with it and
every cabinet's full of junk
food and then I wait for a moment when I
get mad or when something happens or
when a bill is higher than I thought it
was going to be or a paycheck is lower
than I thought it was going to be or my
middle school or mouth's off in that
moment I've set myself up to
fail because now I'm going to open a
cabinet there's going to be junk food
I'm going to eat it or if I struggle
with alcohol there's going to be alcohol
I'm going to grab it I'm going to drink
it and so I in the moment in the moment
in the moment that's not where the focus
has to
begin because in the moment is just a re
it's a it's a it reveals the state of
things in the
moment right right so back me out of
this thing
man um you've created a world for
yourself where you in the moment you are
unable to be who you want to be or you
choose to not be who you want to be let
me say it like
that so tell me about this world does
she not love you anymore does she not
care about you
anymore do you not like who you see in
the mirror
anymore
um she still loves me she says that she
loves me and it's definitely part of I
don't like how I see in the Mirror by
the way I act around her and other
people too in some regards as well
it's I I don't
know how to fix myself in that way I
guess in the fact
of I just see a an issue or a problem
and I just want to address it and I
don't really take in regard how people
think about that and I just want to
solve the problem I guess but you don't
want to solve the problem of being a
better dad or better
husband because if it was just that easy
to just solve it that's just who I am I
just like to get in there and solve it
why don't you just get in there and
solve this
one because I think it's deeper than
that what has happened in the last 10
years of your life that makes you not
happy with the life you've created for
TJ my expectations
for how I perceive my immediate family
should be and how you know we
should we should make this much we
should do this much we should you know
go to church we should just trying to
set these expectations for what I have
my my my kids' room should be clean you
know I just have this bar set of where I
see our lives and then
when it it doesn't line up with my
vision of it I don't know what is that
what is that imaginary fantasy Vision
get you you cuz I have a similar one I
want my rooms my kids' rooms to be clean
my family to go to church I want my
family I want to make this much money I
have that too I have incredibly high
standards um I don't know when when I
don't see that I happening or my vision
of that happening I I don't want to say
I take it as like a personal attack but
I guess I I get on the defensive about
of why why hasn't this been done or why
would you think that or I don't like
that idea so almost every I'll just cut
to the chase here man almost every
person I've talked to over the last 20
years in this
situation who puts external um external
metrics on those closest to them
external
expectations I want my kids's room to be
clean my son's room to be
clean because I know he has my
brain and I know that cluttering chaos
will make his day more difficult and
challenging I also know that long term
for him to be a man who gets things done
in an orderly fashion and to become some
sort of husband to somebody someday
there has to be some sort of order and
some sort of ritualistic cleaning and
tidying up after himself that's
psychology right I know the data there
but it's not I don't carry it as though
it's in a front
to my
um my self-esteem I don't look at his
dirty room as though I have failed as a
father and he has failed
me and almost every time I talk to
somebody with who lives the way you
live is you don't like yourself so
much and you are so um bored and
exhausted with the the life you've
created for yourself that the only way
you can get out of that is to put all of
those negative feelings that you have
toward yourself on other people and you
create these
standards and the standards in of
themselves aren't the problem it's that
those standards are signals to you of
your
worth your value and if somebody causes
your value to be less than you lose it
sounds accurate so I'll ask you why
don't you like TJ do you not make enough
money have you gained a bunch of weight
do you not like having kids do you wish
you hadn't been married like what you
live in the wrong
town what is it about the world you've
created that makes you so freaking
miserable I don't know I think it's just
the unrealistic expectations I've set in
myself and my family cuz for forget your
family for a second forget for your
family for a second what are you failing
in to be honest is probably being a good
husband and a good father but that's
obviously not my front of my mind when
these things are coming
up well if you have created a lie in
your head that says I'm a good father
and a good husband because my wife does
X Y and Z and I'm a good father and a
good husband cuz my kids their room is
always perfect their clothes are always
perfect their grades are
perfect and if you have ex if you have
outsourced that sense of I'm a good
husband and a good dad to the
performance of other people when they
fail in their performance then you
suddenly are a
failure do you realize how you've made
your wife and your kids your kids your
support
card and that's not their
job you're
right you're right is that
fair yeah
and and since I wrote Into the show it
it's been a little bit and I've I've
been told for my wife that things have
been getting better and I've been
criticizing her less and not not
dismissing her opinions when it comes to
our life to decisions as much yeah I
you're still headed straight for divorce
court because this is not going to be
done by just reducing it to a trickle
you have to change your
life how serious are you about keeping
this
marriage oh 100% how serious are you
about keeping your
kids th% do you understand you're about
to lose them
both I do okay how radical are you
willing to
get as radical as I need to be all
right sometime this week probably not
tonight because you need a
minute I want you to take your wives
hands and by the way don't read the
comments on this cuz you're going to get
a bunch of moronic idiots who have never
held a marriage together and don't know
what being a good father looks like okay
you got you got you promise me on that
one I promise you all right by the time
this comes out you'll have already done
a 30-day challenge I'm giving you 30
days
okay right actually you know what I take
that back
tonight I want you to put the kids to
bed and tell your wife you have
something important to talk to her
about and I want you to get on both of
your knees in front of your wife and
hold both of her hands and say I am so
sorry I'm begging for your
forgiveness will you forgive me for the
man I have become and the way I've
treated you and our
children I'm
sorry no
explanations no but you know because
just beg for forgiveness because she's
walking out the
door
okay okay that's number one number two I
want you to look her in the eye and say
this little Act Right Here means nothing
if I don't back it up with
action so I want you both to get up and
sit at a table and I want you to get out
a pen and a paper and ask her this
question how can I love
you and tell her I'm not going to
respond I'm not going to speak I'm
simply going to write this down here's
what we're doing we are over hitting the
pendulum the other way there's going to
have to be some balance here but right
now you have to change the way you
interact with the most important people
in your
life and so this can't pass your
algorithm just can't pass your rational
thinking that doesn't even make sense
but you go by the gas station every day
why should I fill up your car I'm going
to fill your car up with gas every
Sunday night and I'm going to pray for
you and our marriage on the way to the
gas station on the way back it's going
to be an act of monastic
service after the kids are in bed after
you're in bed I'm going to get in the
car and I'm going to drive it I'm going
to pray for you and our marriage and I'm
going to fill your car up with gas every
Sunday
night and if she says when I get home
from work I just want to talk to you and
I don't want to be told how dumb I am
and I don't want you looking at which
things aren't done in the
house and that leads me number three
every time you walk in the house and
start to criticize something you go do
it I can't believe there's dishes left
in I'm going to go do those
dishes he isn't Forever This is for 30
days CU I want you to begin to switch
your body's understanding of what being
a husband is a husband is not um your
wife performing for you so that you feel
good about yourself a husband is about
service and so I want you to begin
looking at challenges in your home quote
unquote problems messes little things
big things not as things to point out
for other people to fix for you but for
ways you can
serve
you see the flip
there I do you're still going to notice
the carpet that needs to be vacuumed
you're still going to notice the kids
clothes in the corner but instead of
noticing them as wife failures thus
husband failure you're going to notice
them as oh sweet I get to serve my
family I think that perspective would
definitely help is that
fair that's fair okay for 30
days every time you criticize her you
have to send $25 to the charity of her
choice now that doesn't mean you don't
get an opinion in your own home what
that means is you have to be a man of
strength and bravery and you have to say
the word
I not you didn't you have to say I need
to come up with a solution about all
these dirty clothes everywhere how can I
help verses you always leave all the you
see what I'm saying see the
difference definitely
hey hun when I get home I have this
picture in my head that we're going to
have like dinner is going to be ready to
rock and roll and I know you're running
around with the kids I know you've got
your own job I know whatever's going on
in your life what can I do to help
this see how one is an
invitation a curious invitation and the
other is an accusation and a
criticism every time you use the word
you you're going to put $25 in a jar or
you're going to write a check and you're
going to send it to wherever she wants
you to send it fair that's Fair okay on
a daily basis this is number four before
she leaves the house I want you to hold
her ask her can I give you a hug a long
one and I want you to hold her and
there's not going to be an Roi on this
hug that's immediate there's not going
to be like I've got 15 seconds not that
I'm gonna hold my
wife and then I want you to ask her how
can I love you
today and here's what we're doing dude
we are
practicing
okay we're practicing whenever you see
your kid's room messed up and it starts
to set off I'm failing as a dad and
those kids need to relax
man relax my office in my house is an
absolute nightmare it's a disaster right
now it shouldn't be but it
is and I had an incredible Financial
year and I wrote two best-selling books
over the last two years and I've got a
good show my life's okay your kid kids
are going to be
fine
okay okay if I have to make a an error
one way or the other I'd rather my kids
want to come home and be with me than
have had a perfectly made bed their
whole
childhood is making your bed important
absolutely it's picking up your clothes
important lesson to teach kids no
question about
it am I going to burn my relationship
with my kids to the ground over that no
way
and that's and I I realize that when I'm
in those after I'm in those situations
and I just feel guilt after that like
doing their homework with them and I get
frustrated and why don't you understand
this and then after the fact that
they're just sad and so you're gonna
here's number five I'm giving it to you
you have to begin to Circle back and say
I'm sorry your Daddy messed that
up do you forgive
me and they'll say it's okay Daddy and
you'll say no it's not cuz Dad shouldn't
talk to their kids like that I'm sorry I
know you're trying your best I remember
how hard school was for me
too you see how easy that is
man yeah like I can feel my shoulders
relaxing just saying that it takes so
much pressure off that you have to be
this perfect thing and then you have
that guilt and shame the only way you
can feel guilt the the guilt and shame
the only way you can make it go away is
to then try to feel powerful again the
only way you can feel powerful is by
beating up on your wife and your kids
again and it just creates this this Loop
That Never Ends until your wife walks
out the
door and so you have to open your hands
and let it go and you're going to find a
strange thing the more you honor your
wife the more you say I'm sorry to your
kids when you blow up by the way I'd
have a family meeting where you say
Daddy has become very mean
and I don't like it anymore and Dad's
going to make some big changes around
here but sometimes I'm going to have to
just walk away for a minute because
that's daddy working on and practicing
not being mean and so if I walk away I
want you to know it's cuz I love you I
want you to tell your kids that I want
you to tell your wife
that you got to stop the cycle man is
that fair that's fair absolutely okay so
I've given you the road map dude I'm
also going to send you a copy of my book
build a non-anxious life it's got a road
map in there too and my guess is you
have built for yourself such a tightly
wound
life that it is hard to maneuver inside
of that thing and so it's just leaking
out on everybody you
love I will say this I'm proud of you
for saying I've got to I've got to do
something different because you don't
like criticizing all the time you don't
you miss your
wife you don't you like sitting there
working on homework with your kids even
when it's frustrating and hard but you
don't like that look when you say are
you kidding me how do you not know this
and they just drop their
head you don't want this either no dad
[Music]
does be with your family not over
them be with your family and when you're
going to find his service and
Leadership comes underneath people and
lifts them up it doesn't Lord over
them I've given you the road M my
brother hang on the line I'll hook you
up with this book too best of luck to
you man I hope you change
everything I think you can we'll be
right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone some people think
relationships are going to be easy if
they're going to be right that's almost
never true great relationships get that
way because both people put in the work
to make them great and therapy can be a
place to work through the challenges you
face in all of your relationships
whether with friends people at work your
romantic partner or even how you get
along with yourself so if you're
thinking about starting therapy I want
you to try better help because therapy
isn't just for people who've experienced
trauma it's great for building skills so
you can be the best version of yourself
so you can show up in those
relationships and do your part to make
the relationship great better help is
completely online so it's flexible
enough to fit your schedule just fill
out a short questionnaire to get match
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapist at any time for no
extra cost find the PATH forward to make
all of your relationships incredible
visit betterhelp.com delonay to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com dealone
all right let's go out to Toronto Canada
and talk to Emma hey
Emma hi what's
up um strange um it's like I know all
the
people real life just mixed do
what like my virtual and real life just
mixed it kind of did um all through high
school and college when I would date
people would be like oh this is strange
and so hey used to that so it's okay so
what's
up uh I'm good um but frustrated which
is why I was calling Let's Do It um and
I wrote down my question because I'm not
sure I would be able to say it otherwise
perfect perfect read it read away so so
my question is basically how do I make
myself do the things that I want and
need to do and uh to explain I'm 33
years old and up to my mid 20s I was
always top of my class had a full
scholarship for my PhD and I was working
on it from morning to evening I would
wake up early go to the library where I
would stay until closing time then go to
a cafe and work until midnight and I
loved it the library was my home and my
community and my safe space um then met
the wonderful man who's now my husband
and in the past seven years we got
married moved around a lot and had three
sweet sweet little kids um but my kids
are all in daycare now um I'm we just
arrived in Canada 5 months ago so I'm
still working on a work visa um so I
have time to complete my PhD and other
stuff um when the kids are not at home
and yet I just don't work like I'm three
years already without a scholarship my
PhD is incomplete it's a monstrous 600
page research that I'm now trying to
edit down I studied for teaching
certificate last year in order to get a
job but I have one seminar work left to
do in order to get that certificate and
yet I'm procrastinating on that too um I
when I my kids are in school I just sit
down to work but I end up scrolling
through Facebook or watching YouTube or
cooking and then I get frustrated on
myself and avoid that feeling through
scaring on my phone even in front of my
kids and my
husband I just seem to be in a constant
state of distractability and frustration
and avoidance I lost all
self-respect I'm
lonely my friends and husband have all
gone on to become
respectable adults who earn money who
keep on studying and learning and I'm
just stuck in a rough and I just feel
like it's all my fault and that I'm lazy
and
useless so how do I make myself do what
I want and need to do why am I not
letting myself do what I want to do and
how to I give my self- discipline
back you may be one of the bravest
people I've talked to in in a long long
time thank you and I'll just say this
it's one of my great honors to talk to
you thank
you
man as you described your last uh 10
years it's it's fascinating to me how
you and I so quickly land on very
different pictures
of what strength and accomplishment
and
um uh uh awesomeness to sound like a
high school kid uh look
like I've got two phds right so I can
talk from some some some gut knowledge
here okay
yeah in the last seven
years I've written a few
books and it sucks right you got to get
up early and I got two little kids too
so you got to deal with the kids and I'm
married and I got a job and then you
right in the night time you on the
weekends and all
that Emma you grew three human
beings and you kept him
alive yeah but that's supposed to be the
basic to stay there where in bloody hell
did you get the
story that some arbitrary academic
certificate was of more Global
importance more accomplishment in
achievement because it's not about the
accomplishment I love the learning I
love the research I love the study okay
but I it when I do it do you love it or
did you love it no I still do whenever I
managed to make myself sit down and work
I just remember every time while I love
doing it and for some reason the next
day I again a contra P that
trick it's just beautiful I mean I'm
working on something so interesting and
fascinating and you and and I just
that's why it's got to be 600 pages I
explored every single aspect of it I
know but you're a different person seven
years later
Emma but I can't stop now that's not
true it is it's absolutely not true and
here's how I know that for a
fact I'm one course short from something
I've never talked about this publicly
one
course I've had an incomplete for going
on 5 years
now every semester I emailed the
professor and say can I get this thing
knocked out and she responds absolutely
waiting on
you and I don't do
it and it occurred to me
recently my life has moved
on now I'm stubborn as a mule I'm gonna
go grind it out so I can get this thing
done
and here's what's crazy I'll never talk
about it no one no one in my world's
going to know about it my wife
might but my life has changed I have
different priorities and different
values
now and if I have an like a weekend I
got really sick this past weekend and I
read an entire
book and then a half of another one oh
my gosh I loved it it was
heavenly right I had my highlighter out
I read I laid in bed I would fall asleep
I'd wake up and read some more I took
tons of
notes and that's not my life
anymore and I can grieve that's not my
life
anymore give me something I don't want
to grieve this one I want to live this
one but you I feel like you're at war
with your body I am but but I want it so
badly okay so let's take let's take
another track here what if your body's
right what if it's right but but it's
not just the PHD it's practically
everything I need to do what is that
it's when we first arrived and I had to
take care of getting my paperwork for my
permanent residency that's my husband
help me take care of that paperwork
money everything okay but have you given
I need to do in adult life where's Home
not just my PhD where's
Home not Canada okay far
away
yeah will you give your body a
minute it doesn't even know the air it's
breathing or the ground it's walking on
con really you know I'm 33 years old we
I've not lived for longer than 4 years
in one place in my
life I come always moving I've actually
only lived twice for 4 years in one
place it's not going to change we're
here only for 3 years
okay well here's what I'm telling you as
directly as I can cuz I love
you you're going to keep hammering away
and I did it I'm I am 10 years ahead of
you or 15 years ahead of you I did it
my body said
stop then I had a kid that we lost a lot
of pregnancies and we had another kid
and my body said dude stop for a
second and I
didn't and I almost lost everything
Emma how did you make yourself do
it if I had to do it over again I would
have done it very very differently
how I would have
relaxed I would have taken what way how
I would have honored the season I'm in
you're 33 years
old I mean this with all due respect but
you're just getting
started I didn't start my second PhD
till I was 35 my mom didn't start hers
until she was
you got three little kids in daycare
you're in a whole new country you're
unable to work the government won't even
let you
work yeah but I don't want to be
spending my days just scrolling through
Facebook or listening to YouTube 1
million perc I got you on that one
you're right on
that the only way I found the only way I
found success there is to be
draconian
to turn screens off give passwords to
somebody that I care
about get rid of them delete everything
off of them which is tough if you move
countries because that's your Lifeline
right
yeah me and so I want you to look at
your
brain as recognizing it is lonely and as
scared as it has ever been and this
magic little box is giving you a
Lifeline to your former
life yeah and like heroin it needs just
a little drip
please this isn't some big Cosmic moral
failure on your
part this is your body trying to
adjust okay yeah
although with the news these days I know
I know that doesn't do anyone any good
either but can you solve
that yeah I guess I got to be dra
Draconian as you said no is there
anything Emma can do in Canada with
three
kids to solve some political challenges
back
home no but I can be helpful
here there are some things I can do to
help from here more importantly than
that there's some things you can do you
can get to know your
neighbors you can make the suburbs
everything's quiet and empty and is's no
one on the street there's not but if you
go put flyers in people's doors and say
I'm having coffee at my house every
morning at 6:00 somebody will show
up doesn't look like it's snowing
outside I know I know and that's the
story that's the
loop that's what anxiety and depression
do to us hun and I'm not diagnosing you
I'm not saying that's what happens but
your brain starts to tell stories that
this is the way it's always going to be
it's the way it's always
been and then you go through the world
looking for what you want to find
and what you're finding right now
because it justifies the story that
you're not enough and you're not going
to make it and you're going to quit just
like everybody else and you are grieving
your old life the life that was 24/7
dedicated to her academics learning
coming up with new ideas having late
night coffee shop
conversations and that's ju to POS with
hey ma hey Ma can I get a snack can I
get a snack can I get a snack hurry
let's go kids hey hurry hurry do you
have you have your shirt you have your
socks right
yeah in no way are you
broken do you need infinite less screen
time
absolutely but I want you to go back and
listen to this
call as painful as it is to say this out
loud every time I've put something on
the table you instantly have a response
for
it and what that means is your world has
gotten increasingly smaller and smaller
and smaller and your grip on things has
become so tight that even light and joy
and peace can't get
in I don't know how to let go I
know if I give you some really tiny
trite things you promise you'll try them
yeah it's not going to sound like what
you it's not going to be what you want
me to tell
you okay you promise yeah I promise
okay you were been married seven years
so it was
26 27 when you left wherever you
were started having
babies well we've been we moved around
four times since we got married but we
moved country only five months ago okay
I want you to write yourself a
letter to Emma on her on her wedding
night
yeah and I want you to let that naive
wonderful brilliant young woman off the
hook cuz she didn't know what the next
seven years were going to look like four
moves multiple countries three
children and I want you to write her a
letter that says hey I I love you and I
know that you're walking on the aisle
with this man that you love who's a
great guy whatever
whatever and that you think things are
just going to go as they were
everything's about to change and that's
okay
and I want that to be a lengthy letter
that you spend some time on and I want
you to promise me that you're going to
start a daily journaling
practice period okay okay and it starts
with dear
Emma good
morning I love
you I know it sounds
silly number three I want you to begin
to look in the mirror in the morning and
I want you to make a fist when nobody's
in the bathroom and I know as a mom of
three small kids that's almost almost
never right but I want you to tell your
husband I get private bathroom
minutes and I want you to stand in front
of the mirror and put a fist in your
chest and say I love this
girl and I want you to repeat that five
or ten
times okay okay
MH the fourth thing is your mission your
singular mission
is to find a friend an in-person human
that you can do life
with whether that's going to coffee
shops whether that's enrolling in a
local class that's separate from your
PhD just to go meet
people the worst part about the
dissertation process is there's no more
deadlines it just is yeah yeah that is
the L and so I think there could be some
real benefit to signing up for a class
or a course that has a dead headline to
it that has people in it that you show
up and you meet and you say
hello and if that fire starts to slowly
um spark up again that's amazing that's
awesome and if you find I just don't
want
to okay yeah but you've got to find
people the last thing I'm G to tell you
to do is you have to make daily movement
a part of your life which is very hard
in freezing Tundra of Canada in the
winter yeah used to run I can't get
myself out of the house now I
know the do you have the seasonal lights
in your home right
now what is that want you to you have
Amazon there I'm
certain yeah okay I want you to get on
Amazon and I want you to get two or
three light
boxes okay for seasonal affective
disorder sads
yes when it gets very loud and very
cold I mean I'm sorry not very loud when
it gets very dark and very
cold your whole body starts to shut
down and turning on very bright lights
in the morning has an extraordinary
outside psychological impact a
neurological impact it changes your
brain
chemistry okay every morning I start my
day by going down in my basement and
flip on some of the craziest Bright
Lights you've ever seen in your
life Wow and that's only if I can't get
outside and see see natural sunlight
okay I can't go down to my basement it's
too dark here that's fine and cold but
if you get those bright lights and you
get them cranking in your house and your
husband and your kids are going to be
like what are you doing and you're going
to smile and say I'm bringing the Sun to
the bedroom I mean into our bedroom into
our into our living room
right yeah
okay here's what we're looking for I
want you to keep this this in your soul
write this in your Journal little
wins okay little
wins and if that means I'm going to edit
one page on my dissertation I want you
to have give yourself a few weeks before
you get back into that I'm going to edit
one page and then I'm putting this
down oh but I got on such a role and I
don't care one
page yeah then the next day do another
page is that is that fair
yeah most of all I want you to reall in
love with the woman you used to be in
love with which was you you loved the
life you built for yourself you loved
the adventure you were on you loved your
research you loved
Emma and I think you love your husband
right yeah you love your kids you love
your kids right yeah they're amazing
okay what you don't love is the life you
have
yeah I want you to find little glimpses
of feeling alive
again okay you're going to finish the
dissertation I got no question no
question about it I want to tell you
though on the other side of it you're
going to get the graduation you're going
to get the new name you're going to be
Dr Emma it's going to be
awesome and your kid's going to walk in
and go can I have a snack I don't have
any
underwear and you're going to realize
life just keeps going on and I promise
you this because I've done it
[Music]
twice and that's with every great
achievement a number one
book the best financial year of your
life all those things you end up the
person in the mirror the next morning
[Music]
too hang on the line I'm going to send
you a copy of building a non-anxious
life it's going to be my gift to you you
to read it we'll send it up there to
Canada for you you call anytime where're
I'm walking with
you I 1,000% believe in
you we'll be right
back I am all in on my latest Fitness
wearable the Apollo I'm wearing it right
now in my ankle the Apollo transforms
and changes your nervous system I want
you to hear this carefully the Apollo
wearable doesn't just record your data
and give you insights on how to improve
in certain areas the Apollo actively
help helps with the transformation it
changes you for the better I wear the
Apollo in both the daytime and in the
night time it's small and non descript
and you can wear it on your ankle your
wrist or you can just clip it to your
shirt or your pants and it gives me many
of the same benefits as other modalities
like meditation or mindfulness it sends
tiny pulses of vibration at different
frequencies depending on what I'm doing
and you know me I am as skeptical as
they come and this little device is
continuing to blow my mind mind because
it works if you're struggling to wind
down to fall asleep to stay asleep or
have energy throughout the day try the
Apollo Apollo is giving our show
listeners 15% off the wearable go to
apollon neo.com
dealone that's Apollo a p o l l nuro NE
o.com dealone for 15%
off all right we're back let's go out to
Phoenix Arizona and talk to Megan hey
Megan what's
happening good morning sir how are you
good morning to you I'm doing great
what's up
good well I was wondering if you can
give me some tips or tricks to
successfully grieve a life that I
thought I would
have and accept why don't you have
things
are uh I well let me say this it what's
the life you you you thought you would
have right
now I I expected that I
would get married
and around I'll be honest I had it laid
out I just kind of you know you take for
granted I guess certain things and I
just assumed that by 25 26 I would get
married have the wedding day and I would
have two or three kids between 27
32 and that's what I that's what I saw
new incomes minimal
debt family
vacations and life just went a whole lot
of Direction what
happened where'd it go well it
it's
I what I tried to I did not meet anybody
um that felt right for a long time and
then I decided at 32 33 I was like okay
well I'll just do it myself and so I
lost 50 pounds to up my chances and I
put money away and I up your hold on up
your chances for what artificial
insemination ah okay so take care of
yourself I thought you were like I'm
getting rid of these dating apps you're
talking about like no I'm gonna just
become a mom on my own okay all right
all right no I I just decided you know
well I can do this myself and so I
looked into artificial insemination and
I was like okay I'm definitely going to
need money and I will have better chance
of success if I lose some weight um I
did three rounds and two of them didn't
take one did but I lost
it which was
disappointing hey hold on hold on it
wasn't disappointing that's
devastating right yeah was that was
rough yeah yeah let's don't just be like
oh well like that that's
brutal so lots of money lots of time
lots of
investment and then
okay so then
I I met I met my
man I met him
and it was that
cheesy weird feeling where it was it was
the fireworks but it was also that sense
of calm it was there you are it was just
home it was
peace
and I thought there's my picture now it
here he
is
and over the course of several months I
ended up finding that he actually
is Believe It or Not in
prison
and he was he was wrongfully convicted
of child molestation and I know how that
sounds believe
me you think it I uh I thought it too
um and I mean we have been fighting it
and and here we are six years later and
he's lost hope a few times and I've lost
hope a few
times and it's just like you look up one
day and I'm like I'm 38
now and it's just like wow this
is definitely a different picture than I
would have ever guessed for
myself so let's have it let's have it I
know it's coming I mean there's nothing
no there's nothing coming I mean um
I'm going to put aside The Single part
because that's hard that's a mess
especially these days okay especially if
you think back to 10 years ago when all
these or all of the world's problems
were going to be solved through dating
apps and all that kind of that that
world right which is right when you're
doing all this um that world's a mess so
I'm not going to I'm not going to harp
on
that but I guess the thing I want you to
to Really
internalize
is this is the life you've repeatedly
chosen on a regular basis ande I it's
not happen to you does that make
sense yeah and it's I I don't I don't
regret my decisions to be with him I
think it's more of like
I I just I I feel like I always made the
right choices in life you know I always
went to school I had you know the
perfect credit score I had my Master's
by 30 I took care of everybody I juggled
work in school and took care of
grandparents and parents like I made all
the right decisions and so then I
there's this child in me that wants to
throw a tantrum and be like this isn't
fair I I made all the right choices I
did all the right things here's here's
what you did here's what you did you got
the shiniest pair of tap shoes and the
coolest hat and then nice as
Kane and you've been singing and dancing
for everybody for 38
years and so you did all the right
things but all those things were things
that other people told you were going to
make you valuable and worthy here's how
I know that you don't care a lot about
your your graduate degree people I know
who
are like you hear me talk a lot about
like we put all the marketing materials
I got two phds I don't never talk about
my Master's Degree you know why because
it was a high five that the school gave
me in route to something deeply
important to me which was learning this
material but there was a season when I
just wanted to get a masters because
people told me that would make me more
valuable in the
marketplace yeah I I happened to work
for a university and so I got it for
free that like my mom said well it's a
free Masters I would tell every friend I
have I would tell him that I continued
it I'll tell everybody in the planet if
you work at a university and they get
free graduate degrees of course take
one the challenge is you thought it was
going to feel
differently and that it was going to be
the key that unlocked the portal to not
like more money or not more whatever it
was going to solve
you I'm going to take care of grandma
I'm going to take care of Mom and Dad
I'm going to go do the next right thing
I'm going to make sure I don't borrow a
lot of money I'm going to have all these
things were supposed to be what made you
feel still inside and they
didn't and my fear as you're waking up
at 38 realizing you've been and even the
last six years I'm not going to fight
you on whether I think this your
boyfriend's guilty or
not but for six years you've been
fighting somebody else's
fight and my fear is youve woke up at 38
realizing you made a bunch of choices
every day for your whole life and you
never bothered to ask Megan what do you
want to
do I think what I I well I knew what I
wanted I
wanted a wedding day where my mom could
see me in a dress and my friends and
family around I wanted the relationship
with my child like my mom had with her
mom and I have with
mine I get that
but and that's good but wrenching I'm
sorry and I'll tell you now that I've
learned since being in this being in
this mess it's like so eye openening you
know you just don't know anything about
the justice system or the prison system
and you get into it and you're just like
what in the world yeah it's wild it's
hard not to just to get caught up in it
because I
mean it's just here's here's my we
thought it would be different we when
you know we thought that you know I we
got a postconviction lawyer and he was
super experienced and found a dozen
errors some of which were egregious and
constitutional and the court of appeals
agreed like if this is true we're due
remedy and we were like okay we're this
is going to be
over and it's
just hey Megan I mean obvious that's for
with all of it it's just you are over 38
years you have mastered the art of
taking a
left of saying look over
here because looking deep inside the
mirror HS doesn't it it was supposed to
be
different it was supposed to be
different the only way I can tell
you to I can give you a couple of tips
and tricks on grieving
okay um most importantly I want you to
um pick up a book by David Kessler
called finding meaning it's the single
best book on Grief ever written
okay and there's some important um
things in there and whether you're
grieving the loss of a life that you
wanted or whether you're grieving
somebody's passed away in your life or
you've lost a love whatever and you've
had a lot of loss in your
life
and I can give you a couple of quick
things that you can that you know just
for you and the audience
here I'm going tell you you're going to
have to sit down and own
this for your body to metabolize
it and you're so quick to not feel that
hurt to move on to the next and to the
next so the next to the
next even just in this
conversation I want you to write
26-year-old Megan a letter say dear
Megan I'm
sorry and this might sound cheesy
um but it might be a matter of you
sitting on the floor and literally
hugging
yourself but I want you to Envision
yourself hugging that 26 year old girl
and saying hey this picture that you
have is going to be
different yeah I never had time
to NOP let's I want to change your
language okay you've chosen not to have
time I want to begin to own these things
as
choices because otherwise it feels like
the whole world is happening to us all
the
time and you did take some pretty bold
action I'm gon to go the um artificial
insemination route it didn't work very
expensive you had lots of dreams you
dreamed about holding that baby you
probably started going through names you
went down that rabbit hole and that's
painful but even in this call you
avoided it you're like yeah that kind of
was crummy no dude you got to sit in
that for a
minute feels like a loss you had a name
right oh I had a few yeah and I had I
had friends that were like giving me
baby stuff already course they were
because they were all in this with
you
yeah
maybe write a letter to that little
baby see I would have loved to been
holding you right
now I'm sorry we didn't get to me suck
John I know but this sucks too
right yeah
yes it's not a slap in the face but this
is a slow being held right underwater
and you can see the light you can barely
almost breathe but you just
can't the last thing I would tell you to
do is to get and you may have heard me
say this early on in the show I used to
say this a lot but I want you to get a
cinder block of some sort I want you to
go to Lowe's or Home Depot get a cinder
block and get some duct tape and write
it on that cinder
block was going to be married by
26 was going to be this going to have
three kids going to be
this was not going to have spent six
years with a convicted child luster
trying to fight the justice
system had a different picture when I
was 38 I want you to carry that center
block around your backyard for a little
while spend some time being really sad
and really angry and really
frustrated and your shoulders are going
to ache your hands will ache your
forearms will get really tight and
heavy
and then after five minutes 20 minutes
however long it till it burns I want you
to throw that thing on the floor on the
ground somewhere in the back corner of
your yard or out in a field somewhere
and say I'm never picking that up
again because choosing to carry that
with you only brings misery into today
it does not solve what didn't happen at
27 28 31
and the question you have to ask
yourself now is what am I going to do
now am I going to stick with this guy
just be married to a convicted felon
forever or in love I am sticking with
okay then you have to own the choices
knowing all the ins and outs yeah great
you have to like I'm choosing to be
single for the rest of my life or I'm
not choosing to be single but I'm
choosing to not have another intimate
Embrace for the rest of my
life
period I'm not saying it's a bad choice
I just want you to fully own
specifically the choices that you make
I'm never going to have a family around
a Christmas tree that's that's the the
the you know the the the the story book
traditional kind you're G to have family
you have your parents you have cousins
you may adopt a kid you may have all
kind of things but want you to fully own
what that choice means and I'm not
saying don't make that choice
man but but the more you make you stand
firm I'm staying with this
guy and don't acknowledge the cost of
that decision the more you your body
tries to solve for the Gap in the
Declaration I will live in this town in
this house and work this job I will stay
with this convicted child molester
because I know he's innocent okay cool
you get to make that choice and here is
the cost on the other side your body as
Vander culk says keeps the score it
knows
that that means we don't have anybody to
keep us warm in the winter that means we
don't ever have anybody to stroll and
just go shopping we don't have anybody
that's going to surprise us with flowers
or ice cream and that's okay but that's
a choice you have to own and so when you
long for God I wish I just had somebody
on the couch watching this new season of
you have to go no no no I picked him I
picked him and this goes for any
relationship man I wish I just had a
wife that wanted to go to CrossFit with
me I picked her
I wish I had a husband so I that made
more money so I could get the new Tahoe
no no no I love him I picked
him start with that letter to your to
your 26y old self tell her you love
her tell her you've chosen the life that
you wanted and it's
hard maybe you don't regret it or maybe
you start to keep a cost of accounting
sheet on the other side and say all
right if I stay with this guy here's
what's going to cost going to cost this
and this and this and this and this and
all these dreams are going to go away
that's cool I'm going to grieve them cuz
I wanted them but they're not it's not
the life I chose okay but I want you to
begin to take active role in choosing
owning your
life just don't want you to wake up at
58 and go what did I do I just let it
whole thing slip through my
fingers and by the way 38 you're just
getting started I'm way older than you
not way Kelly is way older than you I'm
miss a few years
older and if you make some changes can
all be pretty amazing moving forward
we'll be right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else of the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point and
my new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful non-anxious
life get your copy today at John
delone.org great book title take
ownership today's song is by Eminem it's
called walk on water featuring The Queen
Beyonce song goes like this I walk on
water but I ain't Jesus I walk on water
but only when it freezes why are
expectations so high is that the bar I
set my arms I stretch but I can't reach
a far cry from it or it's in my grasp
but as soon as I grab squeeze I lose my
grip like the flying trapes into the
dark I plummet now the sky is blackening
I know the marks High butterflies rip
apart my stomach knowing that no matter
what bars I come with you're going to
harp gripe and that's a hard vicing in
to swallow so I scrape these as pressure
increases like khakis I feel the ice
cracking because I walk on water but I
ain't no
Jesus I walk on water but only when it
freezes set the bar real real real high
and go get
it but smile alone away we'll see you
[Music]
soon